el inicio de la reunión virtual de tres
horas y media entre los dos líderes lo
marcó la responsabilidad de ambas
potencias ante el mundo para evitar un
conflicto me parece que nuestra
responsabilidad como líderes de china y
eeuu es garantizar que la competencia
entre nuestros países no se convierta en
un conflicto sea o no intencionado sino
que sea simplemente competencia directa
el primer punto de la agenda
taiwán el mes pasado un número récord de
aviones de guerra chinos se adentraron
en la zona de defensa aérea de la isla
mientras beijing habla cada vez más de
la reunificación los medios de
comunicación estatales chinos informaron
después de la cita que jinping dijo a
piden que fomentar la independencia de
taiwán es jugar con fuego y los que
juegan con fuego se quemarán si también
sostuvo que sus países deben trabajar
más estrechamente y
nos enfrentamos juntos a múltiples
desafíos como las dos mayores economías
del mundo y miembros permanentes del
consejo de seguridad de la onu china y
eeuu deben aumentar la comunicación y la
cooperación
vaivén se mostró contrario a los
esfuerzos unilaterales para cambiar el
status quo o socavar la paz en taiwán
discutieron sobre las prácticas de china
en el tíbet y hong kong y sobre lo que
washington condena como un genocidio de
la etnia uigur en la provincia de
xinjiang también estuvieron sobre la
mesa la emergencia climática el kobe 19
y el comercio este ha sido su encuentro
más largo desde que bailén asumió la
presidencia en enero desde entonces sólo
habían hablado por teléfono en dos
ocasiones para eeuu estos contactos son
parte de una relación que es demasiado
importante para fracasar y beijing dice
que quiere salvaguardar un entorno
internacional pacífico y estable